this is really interesting um a youtube
creator named
shuon head who has even more youtube
subscribers than we do if you can
imagine that it's hard to believe but
she she does um she went to a trump
rally
and she asked trumpists do you think
burning the american flag should be
legal or illegal
okay and then there are subsequent
questions so let's look at some initial
clips and start to get a sense of this i
would say uh
no no no no no no
no i do not believe that it should be
legal however
asterisk um i believe in freedom of
speech
of course not it's a sacred sacred
particle
boy scouts have learned that to
retire a flag so i don't think it's like
an inherent problem
i think that's blasphemy i will judge
you but i know i don't think you should
be illegally
yeah i believe in the first amendment
i would not do it but i would support
the right
for somebody to do it i think when you
make it illegal you're going down the
slippery slope
i believe that uh as a first amendment
right that you do have the right to join
the american flag
i'm a veteran okay it disgusts me the
people that do
so some interesting responses there and
it's fine that not everybody has
the same opinion some say you should not
be allowed to burn the american flag
some
say that you should some say that you
should but
they wouldn't do it or it should be
legal but they
find it disgusting the funny and the
interesting ones are the people who say
it should be illegal but i support the
first amendment i support the first
amendment
but when it comes to burning the flag
that's just
a bit too far now interestingly the
topic
with a bunch of these folks becomes the
black lives matter
flag as you might know you may have
heard
that some right wingers were cited
for burning a black lives matter flag at
a church during a prior
protest the issue is it's not an
analogous situation
the issue with the black lives matter
flag was that it was someone's private
property
and it was taken from church property
could have been a flag of anything that
what was relevant was not that it was a
black lives matter flag
there's certainly nothing sacred or
protected about a black lives matter
flag so there's some confusion here
i really don't like people burning
american flag by the proud boys burned a
blm fly
if if that's illegal it should
definitely be illegal to per the
american flag
if it's your property then perhaps it
should be legal
well if you can then you should be able
to burn the you know the
black lives matter flag and not get
arrested well what if the black lives
matter flies with someone else
if you steal someone's flag and burn it
that's a whole different story
now of course that's exactly what was
at issue in the black lives matter flag
incident
a few months ago someone's flag was
stolen
while people were trespassing onto the
church's property so a lot of these
folks
seizing on that to try to create a
an analogous situation where where there
isn't one in this next clip
you have military veterans who disagree
with each other on this issue we're
gonna hear from vets who have different
perspectives on this
um do you think it should be legal to
burn the american flag
absolutely yeah because the constitution
says you can't yes
yeah yes yeah i don't want free speech
censored at all
i mean it's the first event issues when
he wants to burn it i suppose i support
the right i certainly nobody's military
to support people's rights to do
a lot of weird things that i don't agree
with no no no
no i've served in the military that's
not for
i serve it's a free country people want
to do something
it should not be legal not in this
country not definitely absolutely not
[Music]
literally wearing something that says
the first amendment and he's like no
it's just being illegal
hello hell no i think anybody should
burn
the burns the american flags have their
ass started no i don't know
[Music]
so disrespectful
now that's really interesting you know
some vets saying yes i've i
fought in order to make that something
that
is okay even if i don't like it another
vets saying no no that should be against
the law
um and then the the follow-up now this
is really what i find maybe the most
interesting
for folks who said yes burning the flag
should be against the law they were
asked
what should the punishment be what
should the consequences be
for burning a flag take a listen to this
they should uh not be a citizen of
america where should they go
where should they go cuba russia germany
deported thank you very much
stripped of citizenship deported
to cuba russia germany or china now
germany's inclusion there is weird i'm
guessing the reason
i'm guessing they're sort of saying like
world war
ii era germany i guess it's a nazi
reference
but what's interesting is that cuba
russia and china
are certainly more the in the direction
of places where flag burning might also
be banned and and what's very
interesting is that this gets us back to
the idea
of so many of the folks who say if you
don't like it leave it if you don't like
x about the united states go somewhere
else
typically the places they think of going
to
um are not the places that actually make
sense politically both for the people
that are on the right and the people
that are on the left when you start
pointing to authoritarian countries but
in any case
that's uh sort of another uh
another discussion let's look at a
little more about what should the
punishment be
the first thought that came to my mind
i'm not going to say burn them
how about exportation where would you
where would you export them to
um antarctica is nice this time of year
[Music]
lives burning the black lives matter
sign i mean come on they're not doing
anything people that burn an american
flag
this country's backwards the black lives
matter flies in somebody else's property
is that do you think that's different no
i don't it's not national property
burn them export them not deport them
export them like a sack of soybeans
death sentence hang them tar and feather
30 days in jail a year in jail
beat them up etc extraordinarily
authoritarian for the people complaining
that
even banning someone on twitter is a
restriction of first amendment rights
even though
twitter is not the government
deportation
prison death for burning a flag
that's what you call ignorant
authoritarian nationalism
it's nationalistic in the idea of the
flag as this sacred thing
it's authoritarian in that it imposes
extraordinarily authoritarian uh points
of view
uh or government actions on people and
it's ignorant in that it misunderstands
you know the reality of what is the
first amendment what is the difference
between a government
limiting speech versus a twitter or a
facebook
enforcing terms of service now of course
legally
burning a flag is speech it's symbolic
speech per texas v johnson in 1989
there have been flag burning amendments
proposed over time to outlaw burning the
flag
but flag burning is legal this
is interesting because you actually see
the split
between more traditional conservatism
and trumpian authoritarian faux populism
or as i just mentioned ignorant
authoritarian nationalism that's a lot
of isms
uh but it's a lot of incompetence as
well so you may need a lot of isms to
describe it
actual conservatives might
dislike flag burning but they know that
this is a very black and white issue
it's legal it's speech and it's
fundamentally american that it is legal
to burn flags
they don't have to like it but they
would understand that
the trump cultists the faux populists
the authoritarian nationalists etc
trump has said jail people for burning
the flag
they are essentially as authoritarian as
trump so they go for it
just like donald trump did and this will
be a split that we're going to have to
track
in the republican party over the next
couple of years and we're going to talk
in in the next story we're directly
talking about this
but this is definitely a division within
the current republican party now
my perspective would be flag burning
is legal should be legal there's nothing
sacred
my goal would be let's make this a
country
where everyone is so proud
and satisfied with how it's being run
that nobody feels the need to burn a
flag in protest that's my perspective on
this and of course it should be
legal and it is legal period